all right you guys we have just come out
of the
fabulous breath of the wild to extend
the trailer all right you guys i didn't
really want to wait anymore so i just
have the
uh live presentation here also hi
mastentone abandoned here and today
we're going to be looking at the new
brand new breath of the wild 2 trailer
i'm a little excited if you can't tell
i'm literally shaking here we go okay so
the first scene
opens up as we see more of the malice
tendrils
that we saw in the original trailer and
what we can see
though in this trailer is that his arm
is grabbed
by the malice previously because his arm
was glowing that blue green glow
we assumed that it was the hand that we
see in the trailer
that had fused with him or something or
given him powers
but this changes things there is malice
grabbing onto his hand and i'm sure
there's a lot of theory material here
uh and and this isn't going to be a full
theory so we're going to move on with
the analysis
moving forward just a little bit more
clearly this is not a very pleasant
experience for link also the tendrils of
malice look like a hand
get it a hand that is uh uh not the blue
green hand this is a different hand that
is
attaching itself to link and the next
frame we go back to the tendrils of
malice and the tendrils of malice are
now
spreading outward this could be because
it latched onto a living host
of link now we see ganondorf up and
doing some sort of super villain pose
here seemingly because
his plan is now in action so
automatically right off the bat thinking
that the malice has come out of
ganondorf and is now attaching itself to
link
a new living host maybe uh like i said
we're gonna have to theorize about it
but
that might be what's happening here
because that malice is definitely
definitely attaching itself to link
back to the tendrils of malice which are
spreading even more outward now
eventually the melis covers the entire
screen and this is
this is extremely interesting because
not only does zelda
fall a little bit she falls all the way
down look at this she's going
into an expanse below because of this i
assumed that we are actually exploring
under the surface
but of course aonuma has said that we're
actually going to the skies
so i'm not sure what's going to happen
with zelda down here below like i said
we're going to have to do a full theory
on that one here in just a bit but
for the time being it looks like zelda
is not playable
um and she is going to be maybe
inaccessible
for the majority of the game which i
know will disappoint some people
uh but i mean let's face it that is the
classic zelda formula save zelda
right after this we've got an extremely
similar burst of light
just like the first of uh the original
breath of the wild game it's like link
is opening his eyes
to the new adventure or in this case to
the adventure in the skies
this is why i thought that we were going
beneath the surface at first but
uh again like aonuma said we are taking
to the skies
so somehow in an extremely similar
fashion to skyward sword
link is descending
upon lands in the sky and now now that
i'm looking at it actually i can see
that these islands here are floating and
this is the first clear shot that we get
of what exactly happened
to link's hand if we look at it a little
bit closer here we can see that the
patterns on his arm resemble
the blue green glowing hand from the
original trailer
in fact it even looks like his arm is
taking on a greenish tint
under the uh what looks like brass
colored uh markings
you can see the infection is spreading a
little bit into link's body here
his hair is much longer here than it was
in the original trailer so this is
presumably some time after the events of
what we just saw you can see he also has
some new armor so
again this is presumably a couple
adventures after what we just saw
looks like several things are making a
reappearance changeable weapons the
master sword
is not on link's back meaning somehow it
is taken from link maybe whatever's
wrong with his arm prevents him
from using the master sword because the
malice has infused with him
because the master sword is anti-malice
it's anti-gannon
so if link now is infused with malice
it would make sense that he cannot
currently use the master sword we can
see the paraglider making a reappearance
again another
couple shots of the floating very
clearly floating islands here
we've got some grandeur structures the
let me just say the design for this
new land of i guess not hyrule anymore
is just stunning
we've got some very japanese aesthetics
going in here looks like stones are very
blocky
this looks very constructed if you ask
me
there are some birds that live here so
there's plenty of wildlife i'm sure
just like the original game we can see
some new enemies here
this right here is not like anything
we've seen before however we can
already automatically see what looks
like the sheikah eye
in uh the uh i guess the face of this
enemy here and we can see more
appearances of the sheikah eye here and
here
i guess whatever land this is was
created by the chica
i'm telling you those people are so
mysterious this part i really liked
about the trailer so in the first place
we can see that link can
get his old champions garb back and his
hair
is similar length to what we saw in the
original trailer so
maybe the simple answer is that we can
actually change link's hairstyle in this
but i really like this part because it's
clearly a bokoblin kit oh actually
this right here now that i'm looking at
it is the land of hyrule the proper land
of hyrule which explains why there's
bokoblins down here
and a and they've made a camp on top of
a stone talus which is
really really neat but the fact that
link is on
hyrule means that we'll be able to
travel back and forth
uh freely i'm assuming and here we have
another shot of his arm so at first the
malice
had taken his arm but now it looks like
that
green glowing uh luminescent power from
the the glowing blue green arm in the
original trailer is
also infusing with him so perhaps there
is a lot more to this than meets the eye
and we can see that the bracings on his
arm mimic
almost exactly the markings of that
blue-green arm
which in my opinion aids to the theory
that that blue-green arm
is the spirit of a previous hero which
would make sense as to why it can bond
with link here we can already
see off the bat that the sheikah slate
is making a reappearance
as well as the uh runes and powers looks
like we can use them in different ways
now too
link didn't even have to hit that at all
for it to
freeze in time and then have added
momentum to it so i'm very excited to
see
how exactly we're going to use the runes
right here is another one of my favorite
moments upon closer inspection though
this is actually not coming out of his
arm this is a weapon
that link is going to be able to equip
now whether or not it'll be breakable i
guess we'll have to find that out so the
splash of water right here is really
interesting because to me it really
reminds me of the splash of water
uh just for the sake of time i'm not
gonna be able to find the footage of
that but the splash of water that
happens in twilight princess
whenever you return uh the tears of
light to the spirits of light
they kind of drip into the water and it
comes around uh
just like exactly like this actually
of course that looks like it's some sort
of oh my gosh
link just buried himself halfway into
this uh
uh the face of the stone here now the
fact that this
blue green aura is uh emanating around
link that implies to me that
this is not a power that has come from
the sheikah slate this is the power that
has come from whatever
uh is happening with his hand with his
arm and he can actually
pass through solid objects that's huge
this is huge
not only can he fly upward uh seemingly
from that drop of water we just saw but
he can also
uh cling on two surfaces and then pass
through them
this is going to add so many layers
to uh the climbing in the game and this
mechanic of dripping upwards
and then uh clinging onto and passing
through uh
solid objects and land is probably going
to be how we travel to and from the sky
we will fall down to the surface
and then reverse drip back up to the sky
which is probably a power that has come
from link's arm here we have a nice
gorgeous overview of the new world
above hyrule we can see here that we've
got some runes some constructions
because a civilization used to live here
personally i think the most obvious
choice as to who used to live here is
the sheikah because those new monsters
that we saw
look like they have plenty of sheikah
symbols all over them and let's face it
the shika are definitely mysterious
enough
to pull something off like this and then
this is another of my favorite moments
it actually disproves a theory of mine
being that hyrule castle is a divine
beast
but that's okay because it proves to us
that ganon is doing
exactly what he did in ocarina of time
we know it's gannon because of the
malice
that is actually the reason why the
castle is rising
from the ground and in classic breath of
the wild fashion we'll probably be able
to enter the castle right off the bat
you know if we should we choose to do so
but it looks like it's all going to come
back
to the castle once again because
like many people predicted ganondorf is
positioned under that castle
which is where calamity gannon had come
from in the first place and where we see
all of the malice coming from
currently we can just see this shot of
hyrule
and it looks pretty much the same as we
left it um this might be a new
construction here that's not a chica
tower uh
it might be new i'd have to go cross
reference and double check
but hyrule more or less looks exactly
like how we left it we can see a little
um
bokoblin uh camp skull here as well and
as that shot fades out we get the final
reveal which is that
it is at least aimed to come out in
2022. now of course
if they follow the pattern of the
original breath of the wild
it could definitely get delayed further
um i'm hoping
that it does actually get released in
2022 but regardless that was my analysis
i am now going to switch over into
theorizing mode uh let me know if you
enjoyed this let me know what you think
of this trailer
the the biggest uh uh uh bombs
uh of lord that you saw in this trailer
if you picked up on anything i didn't
let me know in the comments below
subscribe to the channel seriously
subscribe to the channel to stick around
for a lot more
uh zelda content to come and like this
video to get it spread around on youtube
alright guys i'm switching gears peace